uh well thanks to the organizers for
inviting me and for just making it to
the talk
just in time
um so i'm going to talk about this work
which i did with jerome dubai who's uh
now with cnrs in in not in nancy in
france
um
okay so
so i thought originally i thought i
would start by defining the terms in my
title and then i kind of revised my plan
for this talk so i'm not going to do
that at the beginning
and i will define these as i go along
um
well let me define kyle anyway so
so by chiral i mean something like for
example in two dimensions in quantum
hall systems so systems where you
topological phases where you have a gap
in the bulk and you have chiral edge
modes
either integer quantum hall effect or
fractional quantum hall effect
now in fact in this talk i'm going to
concentrate on free fermion systems
and um and in this case we can actually
broaden this and basically then we're
talking about uh topological insulators
and topological superconductors so they
have topologically protected edge modes
which may not be chiral in fact and
furthermore they could involve
dimensions bigger than two
okay and then the issue is um
do they exist
tensor network states
for such phases chiral topological
phases or
whatever
in some
suitably broad sense um
with
gaps for which the parent hamiltonian is
gapped
okay
all right so what i'm going to do is i'm
first i'm going to um
not even talk about tensor network
states i'm going to first just uh
talk about band theory so it's like
basic solid state
physics
single particle stuff um but we'll we'll
go and we'll this will enable me to make
definitions and uh set up some notation
which we'll use then i will describe
some tensor network states
for
for free fermions
and
and then i will discuss the issues of
the gap
and
for the parent hamiltonian
okay feel free to interrupt with the
questions
okay so we need to describe something
about band structure so first of all i'm
going to use um
d dimensional space
and i'll assume a hyper cubic lattice
i don't think i'm going to write
everything on the board here
so we'll have lattice sites hopefully
evenly spaced
and on each side we'll have
which and this lattice really think of
it as extending off to infinity or we
can use something with finites
a cuboid shaped box and periodic
boundary conditions
um and each site is labeled by x
and there are um
n
states or orbitals
single particle
states
per site
and these will be labeled by
x and y and variables like that okay
so then we're going to have a general
model
and so if i use some
second quantization so i'm going to use
indices a
running from 1 to n
and then i'll use operators
c x a
and
they
and the adjoint and the anti-commutators
of these
uh will be
the usual form
and the other anti-commutators vanish
and then
a hamiltonian which is really a single
particle hamiltonian written in
second quantization here
will involve a sum over
two positions x and y
and then a matrix
and it depends only on the difference of
x and y so i'm going to do translation
invariant systems only
in this talk
see why
b
uh something like that i think
and um so this is the problem that
you're given um
and so to diagonalize this well first of
all we can
go use a fourier transform so we'll use
fourier transforms and we'll use things
like ck
so that cx
a
is
sum over k c k a
e to the i
k dot x so here we have c
what
no
who said who mentioned the word
marijuana
i have
and um
and then we get um ck a
dagger
ckb
um so now we've reduced this just to a
finite dimensional matrix problem for
each k let me make another comment about
that question actually so so what the
case i'm going to focus on here
throughout this talk it seems
pedagogically the right way to do it is
i'm going to take this simple case of if
you like particles hopping so i have a
number conserving hamiltonian
and this will lead to the most what you
can view as the most basic class of free
fermion systems but other other cases of
free fermion systems are basically this
plus some additional symmetry symmetry
or symmetry or symmetry-like operations
on the hamiltonian
okay so this is doesn't look like the
most general thing but it's basically
the starting point and you can do the
other things and also if you're
interested in superconducting systems or
bcs paired states um that corresponds to
certain additional particle hole-like
symmetries in the hamiltonian you can do
those as well you can always map those
onto these particle number conserving
things
by some
by some by by doubling the system you
can always obtain something of this form
except with some conditions on these
matrices
okay so it's it's it's not the simplest
case is really this case and everything
else is related to this
okay thanks for the question
okay
um
all right so once we have this then our
problem is basically to
diagonalize this matrix h a b with
entries h a b for each k
and then we get some band structure so k
of course is living in the balloon zone
which is basically a torus and for me
this is just
k running from
from
minus
minus pi to pi so i'm going to think of
the lattice spacing of my lattice as
just one and get rid of that
um
okay so then if i find the eigenvalues
solve the eigenvalue problem
then
i can plot these as a function of k
and that's when we get some
curves here so these are usually called
epsilon k or something
and then we get these curves
which look maybe something like this and
this is why they're called bands
and um and there we are
okay
um all right
so to diagonalize um
we need uh some unitary matrix so at
each k
we have
a unitary
that's n by n matrix uh which i'll call
t hat
so this depends on k
and this um is what diagonalizes this h
matrix so the single particle
hamiltonian
okay
so um
all right so the uh so the columns
of t hat are the
eigenvectors
of r h
at each k
um all right and these eigenvectors you
know each one is a vector in this uh
space of dimension n in c to the n
and as you move around in k these
vectors can move around and twist and
possibly in complicated ways
and so it's first realized i guess by
phallus and and co
in 1980
that you can
obtain non-trivial
topologically non-trivial bands arise in
in in band structure in old-fashioned
band structure as far as i know that was
the first time
okay
um
all right
so now what i want to consider is i want
to move on to the
many particle situation so i want to
take something like this
and if i've drawn this correctly i
should be able to
separate this band from this band and i
want to think of the some of these lower
bands as filled and the other ones as
empty so then i have
m
filled and n minus m
occupied
so i can do this
using a reference state
which i'll
write as something like this and this is
the state where we uh just occupy
each k
we occupy the
first
m
orbitals uh not for k for x
for each
each
x
okay so on each side
x
we simply fill up some of these orbitals
so we have a trivial state if you like
kind of product state
so this is just a reference state
and with this reference state
then
we can act with
the many body version of t
a representation
of this unitary matrix for each k acting
in this in this fox space
and obtain the
um
obtain the many body ground state
so we have a many body version of t hat
react with this on the ground state
and we get
a state
and this is the states with
which uh which i'm defining if i've done
it right supposed to have the lowest uh
m bands
filled
okay
um so that's how it's supposed to be
defined
okay
and um and so this motivates us to look
not so much in at the individual
eigenvectors as in the s the subspace of
vectors spanned by the
by the uh
um
by the vectors of each k that are that
are filled and also the other subspace
which are the vectors that are empty
so there's a filled
an empty
fill subspace
filled subspace i'll call curly v so
this is a subspace of
c to the n for
each k i often suppress the k's
when i'm doing this and the
complementary subspace
v prime which is also a subspace of c n
such that
v plus
v prime is
cn
for
all k
and in fact this is orthogonal direct
sum here okay so we have the orthogonal
complement
okay so for each k we have identified a
subspace curly v and also there's its
orthogonal complement and as we move
around in k these subspaces
can tilt around in a possibly
non-trivial way
okay
um
all right so let me define some things
in connection with that so so basically
bands
are connected with vector bundles
and the vector bundle so basically v as
a function of k
is a is a vector bundle
it just means that let's do it
informally so vector bundle means that
so it's over the balloon zone
so like so each point in this in the
base space this is the so-called base
space
the blue and zone is the base space for
each point i'll just call them point k
for k k values in the balloon zone and
for each k uh we have like over that we
have a vector space
v which is a subspace of c to the n
and we also have the complementary space
v prime
okay and so this space v can change with
position uh in or with k
um but it's always embedded into the
same space cn that we set up at the very
beginning
so that's a vector bundle
and a couple of properties or terms are
useful for
for vector bundles
so a trivial bundle
first of all so we can talk about
topology of vector bundles
um
and um well
you might imagine that we have to do
this using churn classes um although
that doesn't fully characterize the
topology of a bundle
um but although i may mention a churn
number later the only thing i need about
the topology of vector bundles is the
idea of a trivial bundle so a trivial a
bundle is trivial
means that
this is a basically just a topological
definition means that there exists a set
of sections
so again the rank of the bundle
so here my bundle v has rank m that's
just the dimension of the the fiber
curly v at each point always the same at
all k
and there's a set of
m sections
um
which are
linearly independent
at all k
at every k
so i realize i should have defined
sections first
so a section
of a bundle is basically a a
a
function
a vector valued
function
of k
with um
with a vector chosen from space curly v
so it always lies in the subspace
okay
for each k
and this is um a continuous function
so it's defined for all k and it's
a continuous function of k
okay
so sometimes i abuse this terminology a
bit by talking about sections that
aren't actually continuous everywhere
and i'll tell you when i do that
so this is what we have and
um in general these sections the section
doesn't have to be non-vanishing
everywhere but for when we talk about
the definition of a trivial bundle uh
the linear independence if they're
linearly independent at every k in
particular that means they they must not
vanish anywhere
okay
so that's a trivial bundle and that's
just a topological definition working
within the bundle but there's also a
term i want to mention at some point
i don't run out of time
which is analytic
and this has to do with the fact that
our bundle v is embedded into this space
uh vn at each k
and
and so this statement is that
there exists
a neighborhood
for any k
there exists a neighborhood of k
so for all k
there exists a neighborhood of k
um
in which
uh there exists
a set
of m
sections that are analytic real analytic
functions of k
okay and you can just think of that in
terms of the components of the vectors
analytic functions of k
okay so this means the bundle
has sections that vary smoothly
at least in the neighborhood of some
point
take it small enough
okay so those are the bundles um so now
so now we can look at this
ground state
and so first i'll make a
claim here that the ground state
say psi
is proportional to
something of the following form
so this is sum on k
g k
alpha
alpha prime now i really should look at
my notes
um
so this is sum of the k alpha
alpha prime
uh alpha bar
um
c k
alpha bar dagger
c k alpha
acting on this
reference state
that i had here
and first uh i have notation
that alpha runs from one to
m
and alpha bar
runs from l m plus one
up to n
and um
and i should tell you what
g is so g
is defined in the following way so i can
take my unitary matrix t hat
and i can divide it into blocks
u hat w
dagger v dagger
uh v tilde
hat
and minus
u tilde hat
and these blocks are of size m
n minus m
m
n minus m
and these are everything here is a
function of k
and g k
alpha alpha bar
is uh
um
is um
u hat inverse v
hat
and then we have to take the alpha alpha
bar components
so this is an m by n minus m matrix
and i claim that this in fact is a
description of the ground state now this
might surprise you why how did i manage
just to get this exponential of this
thing here
rather than
some something that looks like a unitary
matrix this doesn't look unitary it's
only involved some off-diagonal
components in one block basically of t
so in fact if you take t which is
unitary you can write a representation
of this acting in the many body space
for each k
as an exponential of something with t
times some c dagger c kind of operators
and uh it's it's explicitly unitary but
if you do some lee algebra stuff to
rearrange things and decompose the lead
algebra of it you realize that some of
those
you can
express it as a product of some
different exponentials some of which
just map this state into itself
um or the or the terms just drop out and
what's left is just this
okay
um if this is rather like coherent
states so this is like writing for a
general coherent state um
some i don't know what notation to use
for that but if i write some s minus
with some parameter alpha
and i have for example a spin a half and
i want to s minus is the lowering
operator for spin then a coherent state
can just be obtained using using a
lowering operator
up to a normalization factor and that's
the same kind of thing that i'm doing
here working in um a space which is uh
un
um
the group of matrices is u n for each uh
for each k
okay
um
and so let me also point out that g
then
dropping the indices and things is
really an element of a of a grass mania
manifold gmn
which you can define as u n mod u
m times u n minus m
um and people who are familiar with
quantum spins know this is exactly the
sort of thing that you get
for certain certain with certain
representations totally anti-symmetric
representations of u n
um
then you get uh something like this in
the special case where
uh
m is one
this becomes this becomes
cp
n minus 1
and if also n is 2 this just becomes
cp1 which is also the same thing as the
blocked sphere
okay that represents uh states in
hilbert space up to once you if you
don't care about normalization and phase
as you don't for states
um
okay so this parameterizes this space
and uh this is all the information you
need um so this basically is a
one-to-one description of uh something
in this
space that corresponds to a coherent
state for each k the only the only
trouble is um that some of this space
some part of this space requires g to go
to infinity
and uh then there's some little tricky
business and i'm not going to worry too
much about that
okay
um all right so this is sort of the
geometry of this thing and i can also
show a separate way to convince you
that uh this is actually the correct
expression
or a correct expression
for the ground state
which i can do by
actually i can do a couple of things so
one thing i can do is i can do
particle hole transformation
on the um
on the
empty
part so that the ck
alpha bar
becomes c minus k
uh alpha bar dagger
and then i have something that looks
like
a bcs state
and furthermore i can expand the
exponential because these things all
square to one and so that the
exponential is actually something like
one minus g
c dagger c dagger
on the vacuum
for these operators and this is just a
bcs kind of a bcs state this is one of
the reasons why this also includes
superconductors
so normally you don't see band structure
stuff written this way but um this is
useful here
and the other way to convince you about
this is um
so since i'm going to think of this as
describing a set of filled bands
then
there are going to be some operators
that annihilate this ground state
and the operators that
annihilate the ground state
so some of them well they're just single
particle states so
single particle operators
so uh
so my
so one of these is
these are supposed to have hats on these
are elements of the corresponding
matrices u and v
um
and um so these actually correspond to
the filled bands so this is an operator
that tries to create particles in these
in the single particle states
in the filled band
since it's filled this must annihilate
the ground state so this annihilates
psi and
and another set of these the further
ones for the empty bands which are just
destruction operators
and these have some form like v tilde
hat
k alpha alpha bar ck alpha
minus someone alpha bar prime
uh u tilde hat
k
alpha bar prime alpha bar ck alphabet
okay
and um and so these just annihilate
states in the particles in states in the
empty bands and therefore annihilate the
ground state
now but you can also so if you compare
these with this uh gaussian looking wave
function because of this splitting into
two parts
um
the what happens is that the
let's use some
let's use the one for the empty bands so
the creation part for the empty bands
for the uh
for the empty
for the field bands
um it does not commute with this c here
so it pulls down the g c dagger foot for
in this term
while the other one commutes right
through this
um and if you look at this
then because uh g is related to this um
u inverse v
then uh in another and i'm using the
same coefficients there which are taken
from um rows of u and v
then in fact it it completely cancels i
realize with all the indices and stuff
it may not be all that obvious in a
a simple one-dimensional example in fact
if you want to do the the simple case
you can just drop all the indices and uh
and this gk is just v over u and now
i've got u and i've got v and you should
be able to see that it cancels there's a
firmware minus sign that makes it work
okay
and so that's it and so this is why this
is the correct state
okay
um so you can always do this this is
completely general there's nothing
nothing special about this
is just band structure and i really
ought to be getting onto tensor networks
about now
okay
all right so now let's talk about tensor
networks
so the idea of a tensor network state
is well how can we write down a trial
state in a simple way well one of the
simplest ways would just be that we
write down a product
and for each lattice point we just stick
down a some function
and
and the product of all of these over
lattice sites describes our many
particle state but that would just be a
product state
so the next simplest thing you could do
would be
at least in one direction would be to
say that
say that i write down some amplitudes
and i let them depend on auxiliary
degrees of freedom
maybe on the edges
and i take a product
over all sites
and then i sum over
all of these uh auxiliary degrees of
freedom that i've that i've introduced
okay
and um so and so the point here is that
this
these are just associated they're shared
between more than one site so it's
non-trivial
um perhaps they're on edges but anyway
they're certainly only coupled locally
near to nearby vertices
now in particular you could just put all
these on the edges and that's called
peps
i'm being a little bit more general here
although the things i write can be
mapped into
honest to goodness pep states as well
okay
so um so that's the general case now
what about for my three fermion systems
so for free fermion systems
i'm going to make a state
where i'm going to use grassland
integrals
and
i'm not going to be very definite here
about
these things since it's number
conserving there'll be complex grassman
fields and i will basically have a
gaussian integral and
i will have uh some kind of ck
alpha
maybe just psi
uh
x really
x alpha
and here i have a dagger and then i may
have something like uh
c x alpha bar x i
x alpha bar
dagger
and then i have some quadratic form
involving these
things and i have some matrix that
depends on x and x prime and alpha
and alpha bar and whatever
psi another dagger here
so it's a quadratic form basically and
you can do this gaussian integral and
the idea is that you cook it up well you
can you can in any case
integrate this out and you get something
which is again of this form
g c dagger c if i do it correctly
and
this this form incidentally was i'm
supposed to have again my reference
state on the right here
and
again here
and so by integrating out these things i
can recover this gaussian thing that i
had
and and now the key thing here in uh in
this um tensor network form with these
auxiliary variables psi
is that simply that these
matrices are strictly short range so
sometimes i call these
strictly short range meaning that all
finite range bruno called it this
morning so there's zero outside of some
outside of some distance
okay so that's what i need to really
make it a tensor network state in the
sense i've described
okay
and so now the consequence of that
is that for the tensor network state
g
is a ratio
of in k space
or the elements of g
since it's a matrix
are ratios of trigonometric
polynomials
okay so trigonometric polynomials
uh means that there are polynomials
in uh
sine kx
cosine kx
sine
ky cosine y
and so on up to up to uh
up to d
okay
and so this follows from ordinary
fourier transform stuff if this thing
just involves displacement by some
finite number of lattice sites then i
just get some e to the i k x's
and what have you and um and uh
and there's a maximum degree that occurs
so that i actually get a polynomial
which can be expressed in terms of sines
and cosines and these can be complex in
general
all right so this is the key statement
so now we have
as opposed to everything i said before
which was completely general for band
structure now i have what's special
about tensor network states is that
these guys are ratios
of trigonometric polynomials
okay and at this point i don't really
need to think about the tensor network
nature of the state again if at least
that's not the way i'm going to do it so
the point now is to analyze things with
with this condition
excuse me
if you what
is it
uh right and in fact
if i in fact it goes the other way if i
if you give me things of this form
i can cook up something which is a
tensor network at least in my my more
general sense maybe not maybe it doesn't
look like peps but
yes
yes
yes
well i haven't got a hamiltonian yet i'm
just making states
right when we when we look at this kind
of state here
this does not depend on the details of
all the details of the hamiltonian this
only it depends on
what is the occupied the filled subspace
for each k
and that allows you some leeway and what
the hamiltonian is
so there isn't any unique hamiltonian
associated with this
given ground state in general but um
well that's what we're going to try to
investigate if we don't run out of time
this correspondence is some kind of free
decomposition yes just deploy a
decomposition and it comes directly from
the local nature built into the tensor
network
it's i'm assuming in this talk
translation invariants i use fourier
transforms
and um and i integrate out these i have
to invert a matrix here obviously and i
get something which in general has this
form
okay
all right
okay so what do we do with this now so
remember g
so g k as a matrix
well i wrote it one way here but now
that i realize that these things are
rate these elements are now
ratios of trigonometric polynomials
let me introduce some different matrices
without the hats
u inverse v
okay
and u inverse
u and v
are matrices
of with trigonometric polynomial entries
okay
now i could also have done it the other
way around i could have also written it
as v
v tilde
utility inverse and put the inverse one
on the right
and and this is how i get
these different matrices
okay
and so the consequence of this now
is
now i can go back to my
destruction operators that annihilate
the ground state
um okay now these i should have put a
hat on because i used hats on the
coefficients i want to define different
ones
and so
so again i have these things
for example d minus k alpha without the
hat
is some uk alpha alpha prime c k alpha
prime dagger
plus sum on alpha bar
uh v k alpha alpha bar ck alpha bar
dagger so these don't involve the hats
and these are elements of u and v
okay and this
so this
annihilates the ground state and so does
the other one
which
has the alpha bar index
the other one is constructed with from u
tilde and v tilde
now what's the what's the point about
this so these are trigonometric
polynomials
uh
whole matrices of them
and so the fourier transforms
of these
dx
alpha and also dx
alpha bar
these annihilate
the ground state
these are just defined by taking the
inverse transform of these operators d
these annihilate the ground state but
these are fourier transforms
where employer transforming functions
which are trigonometric polynomials
and so these have compact support
okay
um
when i fourier transform i can always
multiply in by e to the i
e to the i k x to any power and the same
for k y and k z and so on and of course
you know when you do that under a
fourier transform that just it just
translates the thing that i get in real
space so i get a set of these i get a
set of these for all positions
and also for all alpha and alpha bar
okay so i have lots of these local
operators that annihilate the ground
state this would not be something that i
had in uh in a typical band structure
but it happens here because in tensor
network states you should expect this to
happen and the reason is that in a
tensor network state um you can think of
it in terms of the fact
i don't have to explain this to some
people
so if i divide the system into into a
bounded region a and and the remainder
so the
so the uh connections are just
short-range connections that go across
the boundary
let's say they're just on the edges as
in
and then
in the schmidt decomposition the schmidt
rank the number of
vectors that occur with non-zero
amplitudes in the schmidt decomposition
is bounded by the dimension of the
auxiliary space is crossing this cut
and if i make this region large enough
that goes like the something times the
area and the volume is much larger than
that so there are many
vectors i can find in the hilbert space
associated with the interior that are
not part of the schmitty composition and
so a projection onto those vectors will
annihilate the ground state and more
generally there are also other operators
that annihilate the ground state
and and so consequently you expect these
uh short-range operators because they
have to fit inside this region you
expect these uh operators that exist
that annihilate this uh tensor network
state to exist and this is exactly what
we have here
i'm glad you asked that
um
so vanier states a little bit more it's
not just it's not just any old localized
packet and it's not just any old
functions here in fact if i took the
things that i had originally
these uh these guys here
then i would get
some operators dx hat alpha
and dx
alpha bar
hat
and these are vanier functions so vanier
functions um
what you're trying to do with vernier
functions is um is you want to find a a
basis a basis with like single orbitals
but constructed only from a single band
and to do that you have to take these
orthonormal coefficients here
and as functions of all k
and you take the transform those are
vanier functions
okay
um but then we can point out that in
fact when whenever the band structure is
non-trivial the bundle the occupied
bundle that we're using here we have a
section really of this bundle
this is basically using a this vanier
state construction is using a section
for each of these it's using a section
of the bundle
and
when the bundle is a non-trivial bundle
in the sense that i defined these have
long range tails power law tails
and the reason for that is very simple
it's because it's non-trivial the
definition of non-trivial is that there
are no
global continuous sections but that's
what we were trying to use here
so these are not not only non-analytic
they're not even continuous
now they are normalized and what so what
happens in the simple case for example
is that is that at some point in the
balloon zone the phase there's always
some phase choice you can make but
there's no way that you can make the
phase choice uh um
the consistent phase choice over the
whole zone which is continuous
everywhere there's going to be some
point where it's singular depends on the
direction of approach
um
well it corresponds to something that
you chose to construct but you don't
have to do this you know no one forces
you to make these vernier functions
so i would take the point of view that
it's a little unnatural because it
involves a gauge choice you see
there's a gauge choice involved
certainly a u1 phase in fact more
generally i could put in additional
matrices here you're choosing some
some orthonormal set of sections
um but they're gauge dependent
in terms of transformations in each k
within the within the bundle
so um so why would you think that one
choice of those was better than another
choice so vanier functions on in my view
not terribly natural objects to work
with for this reason
okay but anyway
um we have these other objects which for
the tensor network state
um have compact support
okay
all right so now i have to try to
actually uh get towards a conclusion
um
ah good question
well
so now we now we come to the
now we come to the crux of things um
all right so what i should do is i
should show you the simpler example
um
do they form a complete basis
um
okay so let's uh let's go to the example
maybe i have another question
uh you'll see this ratio for
trigonometrical polynomial yeah this
ratio always finite whether there's a
pole or things like that
um it may not be finite
when it's a ratio yeah the denominator
can vanish and that will be important
so so so some conclusion here whether
you assume someone finding this because
if there's a pole then
i haven't assumed anything that i
haven't mentioned okay
but i did point out that when
g may go to infinity and that
corresponds to some point in the
grasmanian manifold that's certainly not
going to be excluded
if i want it to be a non-trivial bundle
there have to be such points
that in itself is not bad
and that happens with the with the
typical states and perfectly ordinary
examples so that in itself is not at all
let me let me do this example so so
let's just take the case where n is 2
um and also the dimension is 2 so n is 2
and obviously i can't choose anything
except m is one so now gk
is just a ratio of
functions
which are complex numbers these are
trigonometric polynomials and so this
corresponds to a point in
uh the block sphere if you like
and an example that we constructed
for some reasons that i won't have time
to talk about
something like this
okay so here it is and in particular
this blows up that k is zero
uh so here kappa and lambda are some
parameters
so you should imagine that kappa is real
and
kappa squared is real positive lambda
squared is real positive there's a
couple of parameters which don't play
much role
in what i want to say
and this blows up like 1 over kx plus
iky as k goes to 0.
okay
and the fact that it does this means
that this gives basically it means that
this gives a bundle
a filled or or for that matter the
unfilled band
is a bundle with churn number one
so maybe plus one for the fills and
minus one for the empty band
depending on the sign convention they
have to add up to zero so it has to be
linked
okay and the reason that it does that is
that
is that if you think of this as covering
the block sphere
um it passes through infinity which is
the north pole or the south pole or
something but depending on the direction
of approach you see you come out with a
different number
so it covers this it wraps around this
and this is you can actually define the
churn number from these properties it's
called the degree of the map so some
people think that to define a to
calculate the churn number you have to
do that calculation of an integral of
the berry curvature
you don't need to do that if you have a
not too complicated function you can
read it off by the properties at some
point such as the point where
g goes to infinity
okay
um so this is a non-trivial bundle
and um so it's an example of what i want
to talk about and now we come to the the
issue of the hair and hamiltonian
okay
so because of this property that i was
talking about over there
there are many
operators with compact support
and which may remain now we may consider
ones that uh conserve particle number
there are many operators that conserve
particle number in fact i want to use
single particle operators uh c dagger c
type of operators that annihilate which
have compact support and annihilate the
ground state
and so this is what i can use for a
pound hamiltonian
so this is going to be a hamiltonian
which
is um
which should annihilate the ground state
and it should be positive semi-definite
and so i can construct a pair in
hamiltonian and one way i can do this in
still using my simple example
is i can use um
forgotten whatever what my notation is
how am i going to indicate the other
band if i don't have those
i have one here that's right
and
so the one and the two refer to the
filled and the empty bands
and i can write down
something like this
now if i had used the hat operators i
would get a flat band hamiltonian
okay with a which certainly has a gap
but if i use these what do i have well
in fact the energy spectrum
of these well i can write it in terms of
the
flat band things um
i need to to normalize you see i need
mod uk squared plus mod v k squared and
then i get the same things with hats on
k1 k1 k2
k2
and
at each k i know that this part gives me
gives me energy of either either one or
minus one
um at this point
uh
yeah so this is positive semi-definite
so the state that i'm taking it's
calling the ground state is the ground
state so that means these are both one
actually the way i've set it up now
um okay and so the issue is what's the
behavior of mod u squared and mod v
squared well uk and vk have a common
zero
okay
they have a common zero in fact it's a
it's a it's also a case k is zero you
see the numerator vanishes there and the
denominator vanishes there and that's
the only place in fact where where they
both vanish at the same time
so that means that the
that the uh
so the energy
um
so this is gapless so if i do it in the
other in the other picture in the single
particle picture
with epsilons the
bands are somehow touching here at zero
as a function of k
and to answer the question about whether
these states are complete this also
means that these are not are
complete
because they're constructed out of uk
and vk here and so k 0 is never included
in the sum
because the uk and vk vanish
and so the k zero states are not
included so these these uh
these um states are not
quite complete
okay
all right so now um
okay so maybe it was just an accident
maybe i just wrote down a bad example
but in fact for
simple cases
at least i can prove directly that this
parent hamiltonian must be
gapless
and um
so
well this is partly theorem partly
conjecture okay
so the so for any such
now you don't have to write down this
pair in hamiltonian you could try
throwing in other coefficients for
example if you want things if you want
the parent hamiltonian to have compact
support again you have to use uh
trigonometric polynomials in the
coefficients in fact you could write
this in terms of the original c daggers
and c's
and uh and anyway you need to use
trigonometric polynomial coefficients to
guarantee
to guarantee that it's a strictly short
range
so any such parent hamiltonian and this
is now for all
d
n and m
um
for
uh
for cases where the filled
and empty bands
are non-trivial
any such apparent hamiltonian
is
gapless
and this means that the energies for the
filled and for the empty states should
should actually touch at least they come
to the same energy
so that
otherwise if i if i just said that one
of these came to zero which could happen
um then i could but there was a gap then
i could add i could always add a term
where i just sum over all
uh
a i could always add the sort of
chemical potential term
which is just the total particle number
and shift the zero of energy and so i
really need the bands to touch like this
to say that it's really gapless
so
well
so um
so i really thought i could prove this
well in fact several times i thought i
had a proof of this
not the same proof each time
but it seems to be difficult at least
from the way i'm approaching things
so
um
so really i can prove this for
all dimensions d
and n is 2r3
and m of course is less than n that
means m is basically one
so in those cases i can
i can prove it maybe i can if i yeah
um i seem to be having difficulty doing
such things for for for more general
cases there are mathematical subtleties
that i won't get into now unless someone
asks but i can
but i can sketch for let's say for
example for n is two
um
um i can sketch this i guess
uh which way shall i do this let me do
the more general
um
okay
so let me do actually let's do
all n
and
m is one okay so let's so the filled
band is
is one dimensional there's only one band
below the fermi energy
okay so that's a one-dimensional bundle
a rank one bundle
and if it's non-trivial
then this implies that
um
any so this i only need to talk about
one section so any
therefore any
section has a zero but the section means
a choice of
uh u and um
and v u and v
usually write this as a row vector
so u is one by one and v
is which are functions of k
is one by uh n minus one
okay so this is the section
and because it's non-trivial this must
have a zero a common zero of all of the
components of u and v
and so um
and so consequently that means that at
least the filled band part of the
hamiltonian must touch zero although it
doesn't rule out the possibility of
adding this so i also need to show that
the
the other part
above the uh for the for the empty bands
also touches zero and this i can
this i can do well if for n is two the
other one is again a rank one bundle so
it's the same argument and it turns out
for n is three i can also do this by
by elementary methods
whether this means uh for the money body
sense is a wave function of a long range
equal time correlation
um right
so um okay so
uh so just shortly after we posted our
paper uh norbert shook and co
um and and our chair
um
wrote a very closely related paper and
one of the things they mentioned is
long-range correlations which we had
unfortunately missed in our first
version
and and this is also part of this
which hasn't hasn't shown up in my
discussion
and so this
provides another way into this which is
that the
the bundles
the bundles themselves are non-analytic
so a projection operator
to the fills bands
so i can write something down
can write down a projection operator
onto the filled bands p hat
turns out to be w hat like a w hat
for each as a function of for each k
and um and this is again normalized so
you have to uh
so you have to um
so this is w dagger and then i think i
have w w dagger
minus one
w
and so here we have again ratios of
tryptometric polynomials and this is
actually non-analytic at some point
although you have to go to some high
fairly high order in the taylor
expansion to see
equal time this is still
charging
no the two point because of because of
this fact
uh the two point correlator is basically
this has the matrix elements are the
same as matrix elements of this
projection operator in real space that's
right
no
no
it has a non analyticity in k space
and it's got a power law
now this is not the same as saying the
vania functions are long range because
they are always long range even when
it's not a
when it's not a um
tensor network state
okay even when the van even though for a
trivia non-trivial uh bundle the vanier
functions
are long range it's in in in general
it's possible for the projection
operator
to be only short range
okay so you know more technically this
is itself a section of some bundle it's
a different bundle it's a tensor product
and um
and it always has sections
so what's what's really happening here
is is that the
projection operator to the bands is
becoming non-analytic at some points in
k space
and when that happens the trigonometric
polynomial sections that i was talking
about well they're analytic of course in
k space
and so if this is non-anal if this is
not analytic somewhere what it means is
that the any sections of the bundle must
become linearly independent at that
point in order to avoid the the
non-analyticity just by argument by
contradiction
okay
now again uh
in order to prove this well you know
certainly here so here you can look at
this and you can um
did i say what w is i guess i did so w
is
to remind you that w is
u
v in general
these are matrices side by side so this
is this is m
by n minus m
in size
um
in the general case
so again this is some matrix whose
entries are ratios of trigonometric
polynomials
and
um for a non-trivial bundle there's
going to be points where the rows of
this matrix w are not linearly
independent
so that causes a potential problem with
the inverse
here you see and and then you have to
figure out what happens at that point
and one ought to be able to prove that
this is always non-analytic in fact but
that seems to require some sort of
details
study of the geometry of these things
near the near this point
which i don't have a really convincing
general argument for
maybe maybe norbert will
say something more about that excuse me
so this is one argument for why for why
this happens and i think this is this is
probably the deepest way to look at it
there's the bundles themselves are not
analytic so that's just how it is
yeah you assume this a is a strictly
short range a this
is a b tensor which is uh in the glass
mount variable i think you're erasing
yes it did i did assume it's strictly
shorter yeah another does that relate to
this if you assume yeah
actually
then it's not a tensor network state
yeah but but then there's a w mean so
i mean there's various there's various
statements that you can make so so if my
single particle hamiltonian
um
exponentially decaying matrix elements
then my bundle
and i have a gap around the fermi energy
then all the correlations decay
exponentially and i have analytic
bundles
okay
otherwise we can't guarantee anything
all right so i think this is the right
place to stop and i will
thank you for your attention
yeah maybe you related questions suppose
you if it is there you have a pretty
long ring like a tan lattice space yes
how i say well this signature became
very very weak i mean some very hype
could be
but then if you go to long distances
eventually although it might be falling
off pretty fast short distances at long
distances you'll see a power law right
so some kind of let us become something
like little technical you mean
there's a sheltering strictly a sharp
range requirement has a network
that's the point the tensor networks are
strictly short range
and this turns out to be pushing things
a little bit too far almost too far
i mean if i still have time i can
comment that you may think well it's
gapless that means it's at a critical
point i would say no it's not at a
critical point this is a slightly
different phenomenon for example if you
have a dirac point in the spectrum which
really is a critical point
so what happens there is that the the uh
the bundled well the filth the states in
the filled band don't even form a bundle
because the vectors uh behave
discontinuously as you approach the
dirac point from different directions
you don't even have a bundle so that's
what happens when you have a phase
transition here you do have a bundle and
has a perfectly well defined churn
number
so in that sense it it's it's a
topological phase that's why i say it's
a topological phase at the beginning
but it's got this transition between two
materials
no
well i don't think so though
your upper band has turned minus when
you're lower yeah
well they are touching and you could you
could probably perturb this in various
ways and make things happen but at this
particular point
it's certainly not at this point it's
not behaving the same way as um
as a direct point okay so you do
have it might be on the borderline
between different things you could
perturb it one way and just open a gap
and have
have a have a good topological face
so how does the density of states go
um if i remember right i think this
vanishes quadratically so then you can
figure it out
so quadratically in two dimensions means
it means a constant density of states
so the
next
statement development about long-range
correlations so
it's different from a critical theory
where you really have a
spiritual foreign
it's not really in that sense it's not
different it just um
it's probably decaying faster it would
be decaying faster than
so you look at something like this and
it's decaying as a power
but it's a fairly fast power
okay if there's no questions